je sais pas ce que j'ai parce que dans
chaque fois je suis crevé c'est la
première fois que ça me fait ça que je
demande c'est au bar je suis bien ça
fait deux trois jours là je vois je vois
que trouble chez un ténor fait rien pas
si terrible
fait chier en plus parce qu'un machin il
ya un mec de chapeau melon et bottes de
cuir
j'aime bien ces militants colombo est
sympa sourit le biais de frédéric dard
j'aime bien
même ses pattes je suis pas d un
je vois deux seuls et ce que je vois les
éléphants roses où ça regarde regarde
bien sûr il ya deux éléphants roses et
derrière les iguanes géant qui pondent
des oeufs
juste la regarde de dinosaures bleus
affronteront de ceux qui sont passés au
mali les bleus perdent
si vous les moyens et en c1
regardez tous en a fait aussi les
corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux